- One, two, three, four
(guitar solo)
♫ Literal lyrics Battle ♫
♫ Look at me now
♫ I need attention
♫ Hey
♫ Look at me now
♫ Look, where, where are you going? ♫
[Voiceover] Come on.
♫ It's like meeting the man of dreams
♫ and then meeting his beautiful wife.
♫ and isn't it just shitty?
♫ don't ya think?
♫ It's not really ironic
♫ It's just unfortunate
♫ It's like rain ♫
♫ But when you smile at the ground
♫ It ain't hard to tell
♫ You don't know oh oh
♫ You don't know you're beautiful ♫
- Thanks
- ♫ But now you're not so beautiful ♫
- What?
- You're not supposed to know.
- ♫ I'm tryna find the
words to describe this girl
♫ without being disrespectful
♫ She's an elegant lady
♫ She's such a beautiful person
♫ I just want to Facebook
friend request her
♫ Dammit this is hard ♫
- [Voiceover] It's hip hop!
♫ Welcome to the Jungle
♫ We got lots of rain
♫ We got fuckin' tons of rain
♫ Basically just rain. ♫
- ♫ But I set fire to the rain
♫ Watch it pour and burn off your face
♫ I will smile while you die
♫ 'Cause I heard you screaming out in pain
♫ In pain ♫
- ♫ All of the lights
♫ Strobelights
♫ Streetlights
♫ Spotlight
♫ Flood light
♫ Bud light
♫ Christmas lights
♫ Buzz Lightyear
♫ All of the lights
♫ Halogen lights
♫ LEDs ♫
- ♫ You make me come
♫ You make me complete
♫ You make me complete my sentences ♫
- ♫ Bah, ba-da
♫ I'mma get your heart racing
♫ In my skin-tight jeans
♫ Be your teenage dream tonight ♫
- What?
- Eww!
♫ Oh no that is not what I mean
♫ I am over 18
♫ I'm of legal age tonight ♫
- ♫ I got 99 problems
but a bitch ain't one
♫ Hit me!
♫ Umm, like traffic was
really bad this morning
♫ I mean I got student
loans I still gotta pay back
♫ I'm trying to repair the
relationship with my father.
♫ Umm, spiders, spiders
are just kind of a problem
♫ in general,
♫ Umm, I kinda find myself
comparing myself to others
♫ a lot ♫
♫ Take me to church
♫ I stand up
♫ then I sit down
♫ I stand up again
♫ I listen to priests and
then I take communion.
♫ I only come here on holidays
♫ Oh my God I'm so bored
♫ This is a church. ♫
- ♫ Give me a sign
♫ Hit me baby one more time ♫
- Oh!
Oww!
You hit me!
It's okay, cut, do another one.
- ♫ My anaconda don't
♫ My anaconda don't
♫ Adhere to international pet laws ♫
- Oh, she's out.
Umm, just, run, run, run!
- ♫ The world is a planet
- ♫ Look at me now
♫ Look at me now
- What the hell man?
Hey!
Get outta here!
- ♫ Look at me now
♫ I need attention ♫
Please, please, please.
- ♫ I'm your biggest fan
♫ I'll follow you until you love me
♫ Papa-papa-razzi
♫ Stalk you in the streets
♫ and lock you in my basement ♫
Because if I can't have you no one can.
♫ light brights
♫ flashlights
♫ those little chinese lantern things
♫ uh, candles ♫
- Yes, that's all of the lights.
- Oh, the sun!